The last lecture of 6.046.
We are here today to talk more
about cache oblivious
algorithms.
Last class, we saw several
cache oblivious algorithms,
although none of them quite too
difficult.
Today we will see two difficult
cache oblivious algorithms,
a little bit more advanced.
I figure we should do something
advanced for the last class just
to get to some exciting climax.
So without further ado,
let's get started.
Last time, we looked at the
binary search problem.
Or, we looked at binary search,
rather.
And so, the binary search did
not do so well in the cache
oblivious context.
And, some people asked me after
class, is it possible to do
binary search while cache
obliviously?
And, indeed it is with
something called static search
trees.
So, this is really binary
search.
So, I mean, the abstract
problem is I give you N items,
say presorted,
build some static data
structure so that you can search
among those N items quickly.
And quickly,
I claim, means log base B of N.
We know that with B trees,
our goal is to get log base B
of N.
We know that we can achieve
that with B trees when we know
B.
We'd like to do that when we
don't know B.
And that's what cache oblivious
static search trees achieve.
So here's what we're going to
do.
As you might suspect,
we're going to use a tree.
So, we're going to store our N
elements in a complete binary
tree.
We can't use B trees because we
don't know what B is.
So, we'll use a binary tree.
And the key is how we lay out a
binary tree.
The binary tree will have N
nodes.
Or, you can put the data in the
leaves.
It doesn't really matter.
So, here's our tree.
There are the N nodes.
And we're storing them,
I didn't say,
in order, you know,
in the usual way,
in order in a binary tree,
which makes it a binary search
tree.
So we now had a search in this
thing.
So, the search will just start
at the root and a walk down some
root-to-leaf path.
OK, and each point you know
whether to go left or to go
right because things are in
order.
So we're assuming here that we
have an ordered universe of
keys.
So that's easy.
We know that that will take log
N time.
The question is how many memory
transfers?
We'd like a lot of the nodes
near the root to be somehow
closer and one block.
But we don't know what the
block size is.
So are going to do is carve the
tree in the middle level.
We're going to use divide and
conquer for our layout of the
tree, how we order the nodes in
memory.
And the divide and conquer is
based on cutting in the middle,
which is a bit weird.
It's not our usual divide and
conquer.
And we'll see this more than
once today.
So, when you cut on the middle
level, if the height of your
original tree is log N,
maybe log N plus one or
something, it's roughly log N,
then the top half will be log N
over two.
And at the height of the bottom
pieces will be log N over two.
How many nodes will there be in
the top tree?
N over two?
Not quite.
Two to the log N over two,
square root of N.
OK, so it would be about root N
nodes over here.
And therefore,
there will be about root N
subtrees down here,
one for each,
or a couple for each leaf.
OK, so we have these subtrees
of root N, and there are about
root N of them.
OK, this is how we are carving
our tree.
Now, we're going to recurse on
each of the pieces.
I'd like to redraw this
slightly, sorry,
just to make it a little bit
clearer.
These triangles are really
trees, and they are connected by
edges to this tree up here.
So what we are really doing is
carving in the middle level of
edges in the tree.
And if N is not exactly a power
of two, you have to round your
level by taking floors or
ceilings.
But you cut roughly in the
middle level of edges.
There is a lot of edges here.
You conceptually slice there.
That gives you a top tree and
the bottom tree,
several bottom trees,
each of size roughly root N.
OK, and then we are going to
recursively layout these root N
plus one subtrees,
and then concatenate.
So, this is the idea of the
recursive layout.
We sought recursive layouts
with matrices last time.
This is doing the same thing
for a tree.
So, I want to recursively
layout the top tree.
So here's the top tree.
And I imagine it being somehow
squashed down into a linear
array recursively.
And then I do the same thing
for each of the bottom trees.
So here are all the bottom
trees.
And I squashed each of them
down into some linear order.
And then I concatenate those
linear orders.
That's the linear order of the
street.
And you need a base case.
And the base case,
just a single node,
is stored in the only order of
a single node there is.
OK, so that's a recursive
layout of a binary search tree.
It turns out this works really
well.
And let's quickly do a little
example just so it's completely
clear what this layout is
because it's a bit bizarre maybe
the first time you see it.
So let me draw my favorite
picture.
So here's a tree of height four
or three depending on how you
count.
We divide in the middle level,
and we say, OK,
that's the top tree.
And then these are the bottom
trees.
So there's four bottom trees.
So there are four children
hanging off the root tree.
They each have the same size in
this case.
They should all roughly be the
same size.
And the first we layout the top
thing where we divide on the
middle level.
We say, OK, this comes first.
And then, the bottom subtrees
come next, two and three.
So, I'm writing down the order
in which these nodes are stored
in an array.
And then, we visit this tree so
we get four, five,
six.
And then we visit this one so
we get seven,
eight, nine.
And then the subtree,
10, 11, 12, and then the last
subtree.
So that's the order in which
you store these 15 nodes.
And you can build that up
recursively.
OK, so the structure is fairly
simple, just a binary structure
which we know and love,
but store it in this funny
order.
This is not depth research
order or level order,
lots of natural things you
might try, none of which work in
cache oblivious context.
This is pretty much the only
thing that works.
And the intuition as,
well, we are trying to mimic
all kinds of B trees.
So, if you want a binary tree,
well, that's the original tree.
It doesn't matter how you store
things.
If you want a tree where the
branching factor is four,
well, then here it is.
These blocks give you a
branching factor of four.
If we had more leaves down
here, there would be four
children hanging off of that
node.
And these are all clustered
together consecutively in
memory.
So, if your block size happens
to be three, then this is a
perfect way to store things for
a block size of three.
If you're block size happens to
be probably 15,
right, if we count the number
of, right, the number of nodes
in here is 15,
if you're block size happens to
be 15, then this recursion will
give you a perfect blocking in
terms of 15.
And in general,
it's actually mimicking block
sizes of 2^K-1.
Think powers of two.
OK, that's the intuition.
Let me give you the formal
analysis to make it clearer.
So, we claim that there are
order, log base B of N memory
transfers.
That's what we want to prove no
matter what B is.
So here's what we're going to
do.
You may recall last time when
we analyzed divide and conquer
algorithms, we wrote our
recurrence, and that the base
case was the key.
Here, in fact,
we are only going to think
about the base case in a certain
sense.
We don't have,
really, recursion in the
algorithm.
The algorithm is just walking
down some root-to-leaf path.
We only have a recursion in a
definition of the layout.
So, we can be a little bit more
flexible.
We don't have to look at our
recurrence.
We are just going to think
about the base case.
I want to imagine,
you start with the big
triangle.
That you cut it in the middle;
you get smaller triangles.
Imagine the point at which you
keep recursively cutting.
So imagine this process.
Big triangles halve in height
each time.
They're getting smaller and
smaller, stop cutting at the
point where a triangle fits in a
block.
OK, and look at that time.
OK, the recursion actually goes
all the way, but in the analysis
let's think about the point
where the chunk fits in a block
in one of these triangles,
one of these boxes fits in a
block.
So, I'm going to call this a
recursive level.
So, I'm imagining expanding all
of the recursions in parallel.
This is some level of detail,
some level of refinement of the
trees at which the tree you're
looking at, the triangle,
has size.
In other words,
there is a number of nodes in
that triangle is less than or
equal to B.
OK, so let me draw a picture.
So, I want to draw sort of this
picture but where instead of
nodes, I have little triangles
of size, at most,
B.
So, the picture looks something
like this.
We have a little triangle of
size, at most,
B.
It has a bunch of children
which are subtrees of size,
at most, B, the same size.
And then, these are in a chunk,
and then we have other chunks
that look like that in recursion
potentially.
OK, so I haven't drawn
everything.
There would be a whole bunch
of, between B and B^2,
in fact, subtrees,
other squares of this size.
So here, I had to refine the
entire tree here.
And then I refined each of the
subtrees here and here at these
levels.
And then it turned out after
these two recursive levels,
everything fits in a block.
Everything has the same size,
so at some point they will all
fit within a block.
And they might actually be
quite a bit smaller than the
block.
How small?
So, what I'm doing is cutting
the number of levels and half at
each point.
And I stop when the height of
one of these trees is
essentially at most log B
because that's when the number
of nodes at there will be B
roughly.
So, how small can the height
be?
I keep dividing at half and
stopping when it's,
at most, log B.
Log B over two.
So it's, at most,
log B, it's at least half log
B.
Therefore, the number of nodes
it here could be between the
square root of B and B.
So, this could be a lot smaller
and less than a constant factor
of a block, a claim that doesn't
matter.
It's OK.
This could be a small square
root of B.
I'm not even going to write
that it could be a small square
root of B because that doesn't
play a role in the analysis.
It's a worry,
but it's OK essentially because
our bound only involves log B.
It doesn't involve B.
So, here's what we do.
We know that each of the height
of one of these triangles of
size, at most,
B is at least a half log B.
And therefore,
if you look at a search path,
so, when we do a search in this
tree, we're going to start up
here.
And I'm going to mess up the
diagram now.
We're going to follow some
path, maybe I should have drawn
it going down here.
We visit through some of these
triangles, but it's a
root-to-node path in the tree.
So, how many of the triangles
could it visit?
Well, the height of the tree
divided by the height of one of
the triangles.
So, this visits,
at most, log N over half log B
triangles, which looks good.
This is log base B of N,
mind you off factor of two.
Now, what we worry about is how
many blocks does a triangle
occupy?
One of these triangles should
fit in a block.
We know by the recursive
layout, it is stored in a
consecutive region in memory.
So, how many blocks could
occupy?
Two, because of alignment,
it might fall across the
boundary of a block,
but at most,
one boundary.
So, it fits in two blocks.
So, each triangle fits in one
block, but is in,
at most, two blocks,
memory blocks,
size B depending on alignment.
So, the number of memory
transfers, in other words,
a number of blocks we read,
because all we are doing here
is reading in a search,
is at most two blocks per
triangle.
There are this many triangles,
so it's at most,
4 log base B of N,
OK, which is order log base B
of N.
And there are papers about
decreasing this constant 4 with
more sophisticated data
structures.
You can get it down to a little
bit less than two I think.
So, there you go.
So not quite as good as B trees
in terms of the constant,
but pretty good.
And what's good is that this
data structure works for all B
at the same time.
This analysis works for all B.
So, we have a multilevel memory
hierarchy, no problem.
Any questions about this data
structure?
This is already pretty
sophisticated,
but we are going to get even
more sophisticated.
Next, OK, good,
no questions.
This is either perfectly clear,
or a little bit difficult,
or both.
So, now, I debated with myself
what exactly I would cover next.
There are two natural things I
could cover, both of which are
complicated.
My first result in the cache
oblivious world is making this
data structure dynamic.
So, there is a dynamic B tree
that's cache oblivious that
works for all values of B.
And it gets log base B of N,
insert, delete,
and search.
So, this just gets search in
log base B of N.
That data structure,
our first paper was damn
complicated, and then it got
simplified.
It's now not too hard,
but it takes a couple of
lectures in an advanced
algorithms class to teach it.
So, I'm not going to do that.
But there you go.
It exists.
Instead, we're going to cover
our favorite problem sorting in
the cache oblivious context.
And this is quite complicated,
more than you'd expect,
OK, much more complicated than
it is in a multithreaded setting
to get the right answer,
anyway.
Maybe to get the best answer in
a multithreaded setting is also
complicated.
The version we got last week
was pretty easy.
But before we go to cache
oblivious sorting,
let me talk about cache aware
sorting because we need to know
what bound we are aiming for.
And just to warn you,
I may not get to the full
analysis of the full cache
oblivious sorting.
But I want to give you an idea
of what goes into it because
it's pretty cool,
I think, a lot of ideas.
So, how might you sort?
So, cache aware,
we assume we can do everything.
Basically, this means we have B
trees.
That's the only other structure
we know.
How would you sort N numbers,
given that that's the only data
structure you have?
Right, just add them into the B
tree, and then do an in-order
traversal.
That's one way to sort,
perfectly reasonable.
We'll call it repeated
insertion into a B tree.
OK, we know in the usual
setting, and the BST sort,
where you use a balanced binary
search tree, like red-black
trees, that takes N log N time,
log N per operation,
and that's an optimal sorting
algorithm in the comparison
model, only thinking about
comparison model here.
So, how many memory transfers
does this data structure takes?
Sorry, this algorithm for
sorting?
The number of memory transfers
is a function of N,
and B_M of N is?
This is easy.
N insertions,
OK, you have to think about N
order traversal.
You have to remember back your
analysis of B trees,
but this is not too hard.
How long does the insertion
take, the N insertions?
N log base B of N.
How long does the traversal
take?
Less time.
If we think about it,
you can get away with N over B
memory transfers,
so quite a bit less than this.
This is bigger than N,
which is actually pretty bad.
N memory transfers means
essentially you're doing random
access, visiting every element
in some random order.
It's even worse.
There's even a log factor.
Now, the log factor goes down
by this log B factor.
But, this is actually a really
bad sorting bound.
So, unlike normal algorithms,
where using a search tree is a
good way to sort,
in cache oblivious or cache
aware sorting it's really,
really bad.
So, what's another natural
algorithm you might try,
given what we know for sorting?
And, even cache oblivious,
all the algorithms we've seen
are cache oblivious.
So, what's a good one to try?
Merge sort.
OK, we did merge sort in
multithreaded algorithms.
Let's try a merge sort,
a good divide and conquer
thing.
So, I'm going to call it binary
merge sort because it splits the
array into two pieces,
and it recurses on the two
pieces.
So, you get a binary recursion
tree.
So, let's analyze it.
So the number of memory
transfers on N elements,
so I mean it has a pretty good
recursive layout,
right?
The two subarrays that we get
what we partition our array are
consecutive.
So, we're recursing on this,
recursing on this.
So, it's a nice cache oblivious
layout.
And this is even for cache
aware.
This is a pretty good
algorithm, a lot better than
this one, as we'll see.
But, what is the recurrence we
get?
So, here we have to go back to
last lecture when we were
thinking about recurrences for
recursive cache oblivious
algorithms.
I mean, the first part should
be pretty easy.
There's an O.
Well, OK, let's put the O at
the end, the divide and the
conquer part at the end.
The recursion is 2MT of N over
two, good.
All right, that's just like the
merge sort recurrence,
and that's the additive term
that you're thinking about.
OK, so normally,
we would pay a linear additive
term here, order N because
merging takes order N time.
Now, we are merging,
which is three parallel scans,
the two inputs and the output.
OK, they're not quite parallel
interleaved.
They're a bit funnily
interleaved, but as long as your
cache stores at least three
blocks, this is also linear time
in this setting,
which means you visit each
block a constant number of
times.
OK, that's the recurrence.
Now, we also need a base case,
of course.
We've seen two base cases,
one MT of B,
and the other,
MT of whatever fits in cache.
So, let's look at that one
because it's better.
So, for some constant,
C, if I have an array of size
M, this fits in cache,
actually, probably C is one
here, but I'll just be careful.
For some constant,
this fits in cache.
A problem of this size fits in
cache, and in that case,
the number of memory transfers
is, anyone remember?
We've used this base case more
than once before.
Do you remember?
Sorry?
CM over B.
I've got a big O,
so M over B.
Order M over B because this is
the size of the data.
So, I mean, just to read it all
in takes M over B.
Once it's in cache,
it doesn't really matter what I
do as long as I use linear space
for the right constant here.
As long as I use linear space
in that algorithm,
I'll stay in cache,
and therefore,
not have to write anything out
until the very end and I spend M
over B to write it out.
OK, so I can't really spend
more than M over B almost no
matter what algorithm I have,
so long as it uses linear
space.
So, this is a base case that's
useful pretty much in any
algorithm.
OK, that's a recurrence.
Now we just have to solve it.
OK, let's see how good binary
merge sort is.
OK, and again,
I'm going to just give the
intuition behind the solution to
this recurrence.
And I won't use the
substitution method to prove it
formally.
But this one's actually pretty
simple.
So, we have,
at the top, actually I'm going
to write it over here.
Otherwise I won't be able to
see.
So, at the top of the
recursion, we have N over B
costs.
I'll ignore the constants.
There is probably also on
additive one,
which I'm ignoring here.
Then we split into two problems
of half the size.
So, we get a half N over B,
and a half N over B.
OK, usually this was N,
half N, half N.
You should regard it as from
lecture one.
So, the total on this level is
N over B.
The total on this level is N
over B.
And, you can prove by
induction, that every level is N
over B.
The question is how many levels
are there?
Well, at the bottom,
so, dot, dot,
dot, at the bottom of this
recursion tree we should get
something of size M,
and then we're paying M over B.
Actually here we're paying M
over B.
So, it's a good thing those
match.
They should.
So here, we have a bunch of
leaves, all the size M over B.
You can also compute the number
of leaves here is N over M.
If you want to be extra sure,
you should always check the
leaf level.
It's a good idea.
So we have N over M leaves,
each costing M over B.
This is an M.
So, this is N over B also.
So, every level here is N over
B memory transfers.
And the number of levels is one
N over B?
Log N over B.
Yep, that's right.
I just didn't hear it right.
OK, we are starting at N.
We're getting down to M.
So, you can think of it as log
N, the whole binary tree minus
the subtrees log M,
and that's the same as log N
over M, OK, or however you want
to think about it.
The point is that this is a log
base two.
That's where we are not doing
so great.
So this is actually a pretty
good algorithm.
So let me write the solution
over here.
So, the number of memory
transfers on N items is going to
be the number of levels times
the cost of each level.
So, this is N over B times log
base two of N over M,
which is a lot better than
repeated insertion into a B
tree.
Here, we were getting N times
log N over log B,
OK, so N log N over log B.
We're getting a log B savings
over not proving anything,
and here we are getting a
factor of B savings,
N log N over B.
In fact, we even made it a
little bit smaller by dividing
this N by M.
That doesn't matter too much.
This dividing by B is a big
one.
OK, so we're almost there.
This is almost an optimal
algorithm.
It's even cache oblivious,
which is pretty cool.
And that extra little step,
which is that you should be
able to get on other log B
factor improvement,
I want to combine these two
ideas.
I want to keep this factor B
improvement over N log N,
and I want to keep this factor
log B improvement over N log N,
and get them together.
So, first, before we do that
cache obliviously,
let's do it cache aware.
So, this is the third cache
aware algorithm.
This one was also cache
oblivious.
So, how should I modify a merge
sort in order to do better?
I mean, I have this log base
two, and I want a log base B,
more or less.
So, how would I do that with
merge sort?
Yeah?
Split into B subarrays,
yeah.
Instead of doing binary merge
sort, this is what I was hinting
at here, instead of splitting it
into two pieces,
and recursing on the two
pieces, and then merging them,
I could split potentially into
more pieces.
OK, and to do that,
I'm going to use my cache.
So the idea is B pieces.
This is actually not the best
thing to do, although B pieces
does work.
And, it's what I was hinting at
because I was saying I want a
log B.
It's actually not quite log B.
It's log M over B.
OK, but let's see.
So, what is the most pieces I
could split into?
Right, well,
I could split into N pieces.
That would be good,
wouldn't it,
at only one recursive level?
I can't split into N pieces.
Why?
What happens wrong when I split
into N pieces?
That would be the ultimate.
You can't merge,
exactly.
So, if I have N pieces,
you can't merge in cache.
I mean, so in order to merge in
cache, what I need is to be able
to store an entire block from
each of the lists that I'm
merging.
If I can store an entire block
in cache for each of the lists,
then it's a bunch of parallel
scans.
So this is like testing the
limit of parallel scanning
technology.
If you have K parallel scans,
and you can fit K blocks in
cache, then all is well because
you can scan through each of
those K arrays,
and have one block from each of
the K arrays in cache at the
same time.
So, that's the idea.
Now, how many blocks can I fit
in cache?
M over B.
That's the biggest I could do.
So this will give the best
running time among these kinds
of merge sort algorithms.
This is an M over B way merge
sort.
OK, so now we get somewhat
better recurrence.
We split into M over B
subproblems now,
each of size,
well, it's N divided by M over
B without thinking.
And, the claim is that the
merge time is still linear
because we have barely enough,
OK, maybe I should describe
this algorithm.
So, we divide,
because we've never really done
non-binary merge sort.
We divide into M over B equal
size subarrays instead of two.
Here, we are clearly doing a
cache aware algorithm.
We are assuming we know what M
over B is.
So, then we recursively sort
each subarray,
and then we conquer.
We merge.
And, the reason merge works is
because we can afford one block
in cache.
So, let's call it one cache
block per subarray.
OK, actually,
if you're careful,
you also need one block for the
output of the merged array
before you write it out.
So, it should be M over B minus
one.
But, let's ignore some additive
constants.
OK, so this is the recurrence
we get.
The base case is the same.
And, what improves here?
I mean, the per level cost
doesn't change,
I claim, because at the top we
get N over B.
This does before.
Then we split into M over B
subproblems, each of which costs
a one over M over B factor times
N over B.
OK, so you add all those up,
you still get N over B because
we are not decreasing the number
of elements.
We're just splitting them.
There's now M over B
subproblems, each of one over M
over B the size.
So, just like before,
each level will sum to N over
B.
What changes is the number of
levels because now we have
bigger branching factor.
Instead of log base two,
it's now log base the branching
factor.
So, the height of this tree is
log base M over B of N over M,
I believe.
Let me make sure that agrees
with me.
Yeah.
OK, and if you're careful,
this counts not quite the
number of levels,
but the number of levels minus
one.
So, I'm going to one plus one
here.
And the reason why is this is
not quite the bound that I want.
So, we have log base M over B.
What I really want,
actually, is N over B.
I claim that these are the same
because we have minus,
yeah, that's good.
OK, this should come as rather
mysterious, but it's because I
know what the sorting bound
should be as I'm doing this
arithmetic.
So, I'm taking log base M over
B of N over M.
I'm not changing the base of
the log.
I'm just saying,
well, N over M,
that is N over B divided by M
over B because then the B's
cancel, and the M goes on the
bottom.
So, if I do that in the logs,
I get log of N over B minus log
of M over B minus,
because I'm dividing.
OK, now, log base M over B of M
over B is one.
So, these cancel,
and I get log base M over B,
N over B, which is what I was
aiming for.
Why?
Because that's the right bound
as it's normally written.
OK, that's what we will be
trying to get cache obliviously.
So, that's the height of the
search tree, and at each level
we are paying N over B memory
transfers.
So, the overall number of
memory transfers for this M over
B way merge sort is the sorting
bound.
This is, I'll put it in a box.
This is the sorting bound,
and it's very special because
it is the optimal number of
memory transfers for sorting N
items cache aware.
This has been known since,
like, 1983.
OK, this is the best thing to
do.
It's a really weird bound,
but if you ignore all the
divided by B's,
it's sort of like N times log
base M of N.
So, that's little bit more
reasonable.
But, there's lots of divided by
B's.
So, the number of the blocks in
the input times log base the
number of blocks in the cache of
the number of blocks in the
input.
That's a little bit more
intuitive.
That is the bound.
And that's what we are aiming
for.
So, this algorithm,
crucially, assume that we knew
what M over B was.
Now, we are going to try and do
it without knowing M over B,
do it cache obliviously.
And that is the result of only
a few years ago.
Are you ready?
Everything clear so far?
It's a pretty natural
algorithm.
We were going to try to mimic
it essentially and do a merge
sort, but not M over B way merge
sort because we don't know how.
We're going to try and do it
essentially a square root of N
way merge sort.
If you play around,
that's the natural thing to do.
The tricky part is that it's
hard to merge square root of N
lists at the same time,
in a cache efficient way.
We know that if the square root
of N is bigger than M over B,
you're hosed if you just do a
straightforward merge.
So, we need a fancy merge.
We are going to do a divide and
conquer merge.
It's a lot like the
multithreaded algorithms of last
week, try and do a divide and
conquer merge so that no matter
how many lists are merging,
as long as it's less than the
square root of N,
or actually cubed root of N,
we can do it cache efficiently,
OK?
So, we'll do this,
we need a bit of setup.
But that's where we're going,
cache oblivious sorting.
So, we want to get the sorting
bound, and, yeah.
It turns out,
to do cache oblivious sorting,
you need an assumption about
the cache size.
This is kind of annoying,
because we said,
well, cache oblivious
algorithms should work for all
values of B and all values of M.
But, you can actually prove you
need an additional assumption in
order to get this bound cache
obliviously.
That's the result of,
like, last year by Garrett
Brodel.
So, and the assumption is,
well, the assumption is fairly
weak.
That's the good news.
OK, we've actually made an
assumption several times.
We said, well,
assuming the cache can store at
least three blocks,
or assuming the cache can store
at least four blocks,
yeah, it's reasonable to say
the cache can store at least
four blocks, or at least any
constant number of blocks.
This is that the number of
blocks that your cache can store
is at least B to the epsilon
blocks.
This is saying your cache
isn't, like, really narrow.
It's about as tall as it is
wide.
This actually gives you a lot
of sloth.
And, we're going to use a
simple version of this
assumption that M is at least
B^2.
OK, this is pretty natural.
It's saying that your cache is
at least as tall as it is wide
where these are the blocks.
OK, the number of blocks is it
least the size of a block.
That's a pretty reasonable
assumption, and if you look at
caches these days,
they all satisfy this,
at least for some epsilon.
Pretty much universally,
M is at least B^2 or so.
OK, and in fact,
if you think from our speed of
light arguments from last time,
B^2 or B^3 is actually the
right thing to do.
As you go out,
I guess in 3-D,
B^2 would be the surface area
of the sphere out there.
OK, so this is actually the
natural thing of how much space
you should have at a particular
distance.
Assuming we live in a constant
dimensional space,
that assumption would be true.
This even allows going up to 42
dimensions or whatever,
OK, so a pretty reasonable
assumption.
Good.
Now, we are going to achieve
this bound.
And what we are going to try to
do is use an N to the epsilon
way merge sort for some epsilon.
And, if we assume that M is at
least B^2, the epsilon will be
one third, it turns out.
So, we are going to do the
cubed root of N way merge sort.
I'll start by giving you and
analyzing the sorting
algorithms, assuming that we
know how to do merge in a
particular bound.
OK, then we'll do the merge.
The merge is the hard part.
OK, so the merge,
I'm going to give you the black
box first of all.
First of all,
what does merge do?
The K way merger is called the
K funnel just because it looks
like a funnel,
which you'll see.
So, a K funnel is a data
structure, or is an algorithm,
let's say, that looks like a
data structure.
And it merges K sorted lists.
So, supposing you already have
K lists, and they're sorted,
and assuming that the lists are
relatively long,
so we need some additional
assumptions for this black box
to work, and we'll be able to
get them as we sort.
We want the total size of those
lists.
You add up all the elements,
and all the lists should have
size at least K^3 is the
assumption.
Then, it merges these lists
using essentially the sorting
bound.
Actually, I should really say
theta K^3.
I also don't want to be too
much bigger than K^3.
Sorry about that.
So, the number of memory
transfers that this funnel
merger uses is the sorting bound
on K^3, so K^3 over B,
log base M over B of K^3 over
B, plus another K memory
transfers.
Now, K memory transfers is
pretty reasonable.
You've got to at least start
reading each list,
so you got to pay one memory
transfer per list.
OK, but our challenge in some
sense will be getting rid of
this plus K.
This is how fast we can merge.
We'll do that after.
Now, assuming we have this,
let me tell you how to sort.
This is, eventually enough,
called funnel sort.
But in a certain sense,
it's really cubed root of N way
merge sort.
OK, but we'll analyze it using
this.
OK, so funnel sort,
we are going to define K to be
N to the one third,
and apply this merger.
So, what do we do?
It's just like here.
We're going to divide our array
into N to the one third.
I mean, it they should be
consecutive subarrays.
I'll call them segments of the
array.
OK, for cache oblivious,
it's really crucial how these
things are laid out.
We're going to cut and get
consecutive chunks of the array,
N to the one third of them.
Then I'm going to recursively
sort them, and then I'm going to
merge.
OK, and I'm going to merge
using the K funnel,
the N to the one third funnel
because, now,
why do I use one third?
Well, because of this three.
OK, in order to use the N to
the one third funnel,
I need to guarantee that the
total number of elements that
I'm merging is at least the cube
of this number,
K^3.
The cube of this number is N.
That's exactly how many
elements I have in total.
OK, so this is exactly what I
can apply the funnel.
It's going to require that I
have it least K^3 elements,
so that I can only use an N to
the one third funnel.
I mean, if it didn't have this
requirement, I could just say,
well, I have N lists each of
size one.
OK, that's clearly not going to
work very well for our merger,
I mean, intuitively because
this plus K will kill you.
That will be a plus M which is
way too big.
But we can use an N to the one
third funnel,
and this is how we would sort.
So, let's analyze this
algorithm.
Hopefully, it will give the
sorting bound if I did
everything correctly.
OK, this is pretty easy.
The only thing that makes this
messy as I have to write the
sorting bound over and over.
OK, this is the cost of the
merge.
So that's at the root.
But K^3 in this case is N.
So at the root of the
recursion, let me write the
recurrence first.
Sorry.
So, we have memory transfers on
N elements is N to the one
third.
Let me get this right.
Yeah, N to the one third
recursions, each of size N to
the two thirds,
OK, plus this time,
except K^3 is N.
So, this is plus N over B,
log base M over B of N over B
plus cubed root of M.
This is additive plus K term.
OK, so that's my recurrence.
The base case will be the
usual.
MT is some constant times M is
order M over B.
So, we sort of know what we
should get here.
Well, not really.
So, in all the previous
recurrence is,
we have the same costs at every
level, and that's where we got
our log factor.
Now, we already have a log
factor, so we better not get
another one.
Right, this is the bound we
want to prove.
So, let me cheat here for a
second.
All right, indeed.
You may already be wondering,
this N to the one third seems
rather large.
If it's bigger than this,
we are already in trouble at
the very top level of the
recursion.
So, I claim that that's OK.
Let's look at N to the one
third.
OK, there is a base case here
which covers all values of N
that are, at most,
some constant times N.
So, if I'm in this case,
I know that N is at least as
big as the cache up to some
constant.
OK, now the cache is it least
B^2, we've assumed.
And you can do this with B to
the one plus epsilon if you're
more careful.
So, N is at least B^2,
OK?
And then, I always have trouble
with these.
So this means that N divided by
B is omega root N.
OK, there's many things you
could say here,
and only one of them is right.
So, why?
So this says that the square
root of N is at least B,
and so N divided by B is at
most N divided by square root of
N.
So that's at least the square
root of N if you check that all
out.
I'm going to go through this
arithmetic relatively quickly
because it's tedious but
necessary.
OK, the square root of N is
strictly bigger than cubed root
of N.
OK, so that means that N over B
is strictly bigger than N to the
one third.
Here we have N over B times
something that's bigger than
one.
So this term definitely
dominates this term in this
case.
As long as I'm not in the base
case, I know N is at least order
M.
This term disappears from my
recurrence.
OK, so, good.
That was a bit close.
Now, what we want to get is
this running time overall.
So, the recursive cost better
be small, better be less than
the constant factor increase
over this.
So, let's write the recurrence.
So, we get N over B,
log base M over B,
N over B at the root.
Then, we split into a lot of
subproblems, N to the one third
subproblems here,
and each one costs essentially
this but with N replaced by N to
the two thirds.
OK, so N to the two thirds log
base M over B,
oops I forgot to divide it by B
out here, of N to the two thirds
divided by B.
That's the cost of one of these
nodes, N to the one third of
them.
What should they add up to?
Well, there is N to the one
third, and there's an N to the
two thirds here that multiplies
out to N.
So, we get N over B.
This looks bad.
This looks the same.
And we don't want to lose
another log factor.
But the good news is we have
two thirds in here.
OK, this is what we get in
total at this level.
It looks like the sorting
bound, but in the log there's
still a two thirds.
Now, a power of two thirds and
a log comes out as a multiple of
two thirds.
So, this is in fact two thirds
times N over B,
log base M over B of N over B,
the sorting bound.
So, this is two thirds of the
sorting bound.
And this is the sorting bound,
one times the sorting bound.
So, it's going down
geometrically,
yea!
OK, I'm not going to prove it,
but it's true.
This went down by a factor of
two thirds.
The next one will also go down
by a factor of two thirds by
induction.
OK, if you prove it at one
level, it should be true at all
of them.
And I'm going to skip the
details there.
So, we could check the leaf
level just to make sure.
That's always a good sanity
check.
At the leaves,
we know our cost is M over B.
OK, and how many leaves are
there?
Just like before,
in some sense,
we have N/M leaves.
OK, so in fact the total cost
at the bottom is N over B.
And it turns out that that's
what you get.
So, you essentially,
it looks funny,
because you'd think that this
would actually be smaller than
this at some intuitive level.
It's not.
In fact, what's happening is
you have this N over B times
this log thing,
whatever the log thing is.
We don't care too much.
Let's just call it log.
What you are taking at the next
level is two thirds times that
log.
And at the next level,
it's four ninths times that log
and so on.
So, it's geometrically
decreasing until the log gets
down to one.
And then you stop the
recursion.
And that's what you get N over
B here with no log.
So, what you're doing is
decreasing the log,
not the N over B stuff.
The two thirds should really be
over here.
In fact, the number of levels
here is log, log N.
It's the number of times you
have to divide a log by three
halves before you get down to
one, OK?
So, we don't actually need
that.
We don't care how many levels
are because it's geometrically
decreasing.
It could be infinitely many
levels.
It's geometrically decreasing,
and we get this as our running
time.
MT of N is the sorting bound
for funnel sort.
So, this is great.
As long as we can get a funnel
that merges this quickly,
we get a sorting algorithm that
sorts as fast as it possibly
can.
I didn't write that on the
board that this is
asymptotically optimal.
Even if you knew what B and M
were, this is the best that you
could hope to do.
And here, we are doing it no
matter what, B and M are.
Good.
Get ready for the funnel.
The funnel will be another
recursion.
So, this is a recursive
algorithm in a recursive
algorithm.
It's another divide and
conquer, kind of like the static
search trees we saw at the
beginning of this lecture.
So, these all tie together.
All right, the K funnel,
so, I'm calling it K funnel
because I want to think of it at
some recursive level,
not just N to the one third.
OK, we're going to recursively
use, in fact,
the square root of K funnel.
So, here's, and I need to
achieve that bound.
So, the recursion is like the
static search tree,
and a little bit hard to draw
on one board,
but here we go.
So, we have a square root of K
funnel.
Recursively,
we have a buffer up here.
This is called the output
buffer, and it has size K^3,
and just for kicks,
let's suppose it that filled up
a little bit.
And, we have some more buffers.
And, let's suppose they've been
filled up by different amounts.
And each of these has size K to
the three halves,
of course.
Halves, these are called
buffers, let's say,
with the intermediate buffers.
And, then hanging off of them,
we have more funnels,
the square root of K funnel
here, and a square root of K
funnel here, one for each
buffer, one for each child of
this funnel.
OK, and then hanging off of
these funnels are the input
arrays.
OK, I'm not going to draw all K
of them, but there are K input
arrays, input lists let's call
them down at the bottom.
OK, so the idea is we are going
to merge bottom-up in this
picture.
We start with our K input
arrays of total size at least
K^3.
That's what we're assuming we
have up here.
We are clustering them into
groups of size square root of K,
so, the square root of K
groups, throw each of them into
a square root of K funnel that
recursively merges those square
root of K lists.
The output of those funnels we
are putting into a buffer to
sort of accumulate what the
answer should be.
These buffers have besides
exactly K to the three halves,
which might not be perfect
because we know that on average,
there should be K to the three
halves elements in each of these
because there's K^3 total,
and the square root of K
groups.
So, it should be K^3 divided by
the square root of K,
which is K to the three halves
on average.
But some of these will be
bigger.
Some of them will be smaller.
I've drawn it here.
Some of them had emptied a bit
more depending on how you merge
things.
But on average,
these will all fill at the same
time.
And then, we plug them into a
square root of K funnel,
and that we get the output of
size K^3.
So, that is roughly what we
should have happen.
OK, but in fact,
some of these might fill first,
and we have to do some merging
in order to empty a buffer,
make room for more stuff coming
up.
That's the picture.
Now, before I actually tell you
what the algorithm is,
or analyze the algorithm,
let's first just think about
space, a very simple warm-up
analysis.
So, let's look at the space
excluding the inputs and
outputs, those buffers.
OK, why do I want to exclude
input and output buffers?
Well, because I want to only
count each buffer once,
and this buffer is actually the
input to this one and the output
to this one.
So, in order to recursively
count all the buffers exactly
once, I'm only going to count
these middle buffers.
And then separately,
I'm going to have to think of
the overall output and input
buffers.
But those are sort of given.
I mean, I need K^3 for the
output.
I need K^3 for the input.
So ignore those overall.
And that if I count the middle
buffers recursively,
I'll get all the buffers.
So, then we get a very simple
recurrence for space.
S of K is roughly square root
of K plus one times S of square
root of K plus order K^2,
K^2 because we have the square
root of K of these buffers,
each of size K to the three
halves.
Work that out,
does that sound right?
That sounds an awful lot like
K^3, but maybe,
all right.
Oh, no, that's right.
It's K to the three halves
times the square root of K,
which is K to the three halves
plus a half, which is K to the
four halves, which is K^2.
Phew, OK, good.
I'm just bad with my arithmetic
here.
OK, so K^2 total buffering
You add them up for each level,
each recursion,
and the plus one here is to
take into account the top guy,
the square root of K bottom
guys, so the square root of K
plus one.
If this were,
well, let me just draw the
recurrence tree.
There's many ways you could
solve this recurrence.
A natural one is instead of
looking at K,
you look at log K,
because here at log K is
getting divided by two.
I just going to draw the
recursion trees,
so you can see the intuition.
But if you are going to solve
it, you should probably take the
logs, substitute by log.
So, we have the square root of
K.
plus one branching factor.
And then, the problem is size
square root of K,
so this is going to be K,
I believe, for each of these.
This is square root of K
squared is the cost of these
levels.
And, you keep going.
I don't particularly care what
the bottom looks like because at
the top we have K^2.
That we have K times root K
plus one cost at the next level.
This is K to the three halves
plus K.
OK, so we go from K^2 to K to
the three halves plus K.
This is a super-geometric.
It's like an exponential
geometric decrease.
This is decreasing really fast.
So, it's order K^2.
That's my hand-waving argument.
OK, so the cost is basically
the size of the buffers at the
top level, the total space.
We're going to need this.
It's actually theta K^2 because
I have a theta K^2 here.
We are going to be this in
order to analyze the time.
That's why it mentioned it.
It's not just a good feeling
that the space is not too big.
In fact, the funnel is a lot
smaller than a total input size.
The input size is K^3.
But that's not so crucial.
What's crucial is that it's
K^2, and we'll use that in the
analysis.
OK, naturally,
this thing is laid out
recursively.
You recursively store the
funnel, top funnel.
Then, for example,
you write out each buffer as a
consecutive array,
in this case.
There's no recursion there.
So just write them all out one
by one.
Don't interleave them or
anything.
Store them in order.
And that, you write out
recursively these funnels,
the bottom funnels.
OK, any way you do it
recursively, as long as each
funnel remains a consecutive
chunk of memory,
each buffer remains a
consecutive chuck of memory,
the time analysis that we are
about to do will work.
OK, let me actually give you
the algorithm that we're
analyzing.
In order to make the funnel go,
what we do is say,
initially, all the buffers are
empty.
Everything is at the bottom.
And what we are going to do is,
say, fill the root buffer.
Fill this one.
And, that's a recursive
algorithm, which I'll define in
a second, how to fill a buffer.
Once it's filled,
that means everything has been
pulled up, and then it's merged.
OK, so that's how we get
started.
So, merge means to merge
algorithm is fill the topmost
buffer, the topmost output
buffer.
OK, and now,
here's how you fill a buffer.
So, in general,
if you expand out this
recursion all the way,
in the base case,
I didn't mention you sort of
get a little node there.
So, if you look at an arbitrary
buffer in this picture that you
want to fill,
so this one's empty and you
want to fill it,
then immediately below it will
be a vertex who has two
children, two other buffers.
OK, maybe they look like this.
You have no idea how big they
are, except they are the same
size.
It could be a lot smaller than
this one, a lot bigger,
we don't know.
But in the end,
you do get a binary structure
out of this just like we did
with the binary search tree at
the beginning.
So, how do we fill this buffer?
Well, we just merge these two
child buffers as long as we can.
So, we merge the two children
buffers as long as they are both
non-empty.
So, in general,
the invariant will be that this
buffer, let me write down a
sentence.
As long as a buffer is
non-empty, or whatever is in
that buffer, and hasn't been
used already,
it's a prefix of the merged
output of the entire subtree
beneath it.
OK, so this is a partially
merged subsequence of everything
down here.
This is a partially merged
subsequence of everything down
here.
I can just merge element by
element off the top,
and that will give me outputs
to put there until one of them
gets emptied.
And, we have no idea which one
will empty first just because it
depends on the order.
OK, whenever one of them
empties, we recursively fill it,
and that's it.
That's the algorithm.
Whenever one empties --
-- we recursively fill it.
And at the base case at the
leaves, there's sort of nothing
to do.
I believe you just sort of
directly read from an input
list.
So, at the very bottom,
if you have some note here
that's trying to merge between
these two, that's just a
straightforward merge between
two lists.
We know how to do that with two
parallel scans.
So, in fact,
we can merge the entire thing
here and just spit it out to the
buffer.
Well, it depends how big the
buffer is.
We can only merge it until the
buffer fills.
Whenever a buffer is full,
we stop and we pop up the
recursive layers.
OK, so we keep doing this merge
until the buffer we are trying
to fill fills,
and that we stop,
pop up.
OK, that's the algorithm for
merging.
Now, we just have to analyze
the algorithm.
It's actually not too hard,
but it's a pretty clever
analysis.
And, to top it off,
it's an amortization,
your favorite.
OK, so we get one last practice
at amortized analysis in the
context of cache oblivious
algorithms.
So, this is going to be a bit
sophisticated.
We are going to combine all the
ideas we've seen.
The main analysis idea we've
seen is that we are doing this
recursion in the construction,
and if we imagine,
we take our K funnel,
we split it in the middle
level, make a whole bunch of
square root of K funnels,
and so on, and then we cut
those in the middle level,
get fourth root of K funnels,
and so on, and so on,
at some point the funnel we
look at fits in cache.
OK, before we said if it's in a
block.
Now, we're going to say that at
some point, one of these funnels
will fit in cache.
Each of the funnels at that
recursive level of detail will
fit in cache.
We are going to analyze that
level.
We'll call that level J.
So, consider the first
recursive level of detail,
and I'll call it J,
at which every J funnel we have
fits, let's say,
not only does it fit in cache,
but four of them fit in cache.
It fits in one quarter of the
cache.
OK, but we need to leave some
cache extra for doing other
things.
But I want to make sure that
the J funnel fits.
OK, now what does that mean?
Well, we've analyzed space.
We know that the space of a J
funnel is about J^2,
some constant times J^2.
We'll call it C times J^2.
OK, so this is saying that C
times J^2 is at most,
M over 4, one quarter of the
cache.
OK, that means a J funnel that
happens at the size sits in the
quarter of the cache.
OK, at some point in the
recursion, we'll have this big
tree of J funnels,
with all sorts of buffers in
between them,
and each of the J funnels will
fit.
So, let's think about one of
those J funnels.
Suppose J is like the square
root of K.
So, this is the picture because
otherwise I have to draw a
bigger one.
So, suppose this is a J funnel.
It has a bunch of input
buffers, has one output buffer.
So, we just want to think about
how the J funnel executes.
And, for a long time,
as long as these buffers are
all full, this is just a merger.
It's doing something
recursively, but we don't really
care.
As soon as this whole thing
swaps in, and actually,
I should be drawing this,
as soon as the funnel,
the output buffer,
and the input buffer swap in,
in other words,
you bring all those blocks in,
you can just merge,
and you can go on your merry
way merging until something
empties or you fill the output.
So, let's analyze that.
Suppose everything is in
memory, because we know it fits.
OK, well I have to be a little
bit careful.
The input buffers are actually
pretty big in total size because
the total size is K to the three
halves here versus K to the one
half.
Actually, this is of size K.
Let me draw a general picture.
We have a J funnel,
because otherwise the
arithmetic is going to get
messy.
We have a J funnel.
Its size is C times J^2,
we're supposing.
The number of inputs is J,
and the size of them is pretty
big.
Where did we define that?
We have a K funnel.
The total input size is K^3.
So, the total input size here
would be J^3.
We can't afford to put all that
in cache.
That's an extra factor of J.
But, we can afford to one block
per input.
And for merging,
that's all we need.
I claim that I can fit the
first block of each of these
input arrays in cash at the same
time along with the J funnel.
And so, for that duration,
as long as all of that is in
cache, this thing can merge at
full speed just like we were
doing parallel scans.
You use up all the blocks down
here, and one of them empties.
You go to the next block in the
input buffer and so on,
just like the normal merge
analysis of parallel arrays,
at this point we assume that
everything here is fitting in
cache.
So, it's just like before.
Of course, in fact,
it's recursive but we are
analyzing it at this level.
OK, I need to prove that you
can fit one block per input.
It's not hard.
It's just computation.
And, it's basically the way
that these funnels were designed
was so that you could fit one
block per input buffer.
And, here's the argument.
So, the claim is you can also
fit one memory block in the
cache per input buffer.
So, this is in addition to one
J funnel.
You could also fit one block
for each of its input buffers.
OK, this is of the J funnel.
It's not any funnel because
bigger funnels are way too big.
OK, so here's how we prove
that.
J^2 is at most a quarter M.
That's what we assumed here,
actually CJ2.
I'm not going to bother with
the C because that's going to
make my life even harder.
OK, I think this is even a
weaker constraint.
So, the size of our funnel
proves about J^2.
That's at most a quarter of the
cache.
That implies that J,
if we take square roots of both
sides, is at most a half square
root of M.
OK, also, we know that B is at
most square root of M because M
is at least B squared.
So, we put these together,
and we get J times B is at most
a half M.
OK, now I claim that what we
are asking for here is J times B
because in a J funnel,
there are J input arrays.
And so, if you want one block
each, that costs a space of B
each.
So, for each input buffer we
have one block of size B,
and the claim is that that
whole thing fits in half the
cache.
And, we've only used a quarter
of the cache.
So in total,
we use three quarters of the
cache and that's all we'll use.
OK, so that's good news.
We can also fit one more block
to the output.
Not too big a deal.
So now, as long as this J
funnel is running,
if it's all in cache,
all is well.
What does that mean?
Let me first analyze how long
it takes for us to swap in this
funnel.
OK, so how long does it take
for us to read all the stuff in
a J funnel and one block per
input buffer?
That's what it would take to
get started.
So, this is swapping in a J
funnel, which means reading the
J funnel in its entirety,
and reading one block per input
buffer.
OK, the cost of the swap in is
pretty natural.
The size of the buffer divided
by B, because that's just sort
of a linear scan to read it in,
and we need to read one block
per buffer.
These buffers could be all over
the place because they're pretty
big.
So, let's say we pay one memory
transfer for each input buffer
just to get started to read the
first block.
OK, the claim is,
and here we need to do some
more arithmetic.
This is, at most,
J^3 over B.
OK, why is it,
at most, J^3 over B?
Well, this was the first level
at which things fit in cache.
That means the next level
bigger, which is J^2,
which has size J^4,
should be bigger than cache.
Otherwise we would have stopped
then.
OK, so this is just more
arithmetic.
You can either believe me or
follow the arithmetic.
We know that J^4 is at least M.
So, this means that,
and we know that M is at least
B^2.
Therefore, J^2,
instead of J^4,
we take the square root of both
sides, J^2 is at least B.
OK, so certainly J^2 over B is
at most J^3 over B.
But also J is at most J^3 over
B because J^2 is at least B.
Hopefully that should be clear.
That's just algebra.
OK, so we're not going to use
this bound because that's kind
of complicated.
We're just going to say,
well, it causes J^3 over B to
get swapped in.
Now, why is J^3 over B a good
thing?
Because we know the total size
of inputs to the J funnel is
J^3.
So, to read all of the inputs
to the J funnel takes J^3 over
B.
So, this is really just a
linear extra cost to get the
whole thing swapped in.
It sounds good.
To do the merging would also
cost J^3 over B.
So, the swap-in causes J^3 over
B to merge all these J^3
elements.
If they were all there in the
inputs, it would take J^3 over B
because once everything is
there, you're merging at full
speed, one per B items per
memory transfer on average.
OK, the problem is you're going
to swap out, which you may have
imagined.
As soon as one of your input
buffers empties,
let's say this one's almost
gone, as soon as it empties,
you're going to totally
obliterate that funnel and swap
in this one in order to merge
all the stuff there,
and fill this buffer back up.
This is where the amortization
comes in.
And this is where the log
factor comes in because so far
it we've basically paid a linear
cost.
We are almost done.
So, we charge,
sorry, I'm jumping ahead of
myself.
So, when an input buffer
empties, we swap out.
And we recursively fill that
buffer.
OK, I'm going to assume that
there is absolutely no reuse,
that is recursive filling
completely swapped everything
out and I have to start from
scratch for this funnel.
So, when that happens,
I feel this buffer,
and then I come back and I say,
well, I go swap it back in.
So when the recursive call
finishes, I swap back in.
OK, so I recursively fill,
and then I swap back in.
And, at the swapping back in
costs J^3 over B.
I'm going to charge that cost
to the elements that just got
filled.
So this is an amortized
charging argument.
How many are there?
It's the only question.
It turns out,
things are really good,
like here, for the square root
of K funnel, we have each buffer
has size K to the three halves.
OK, so this is a bit
complicated.
But I claim that the number of
elements here that fill the
buffer is J^3.
So, if you have a J funnel,
each of the input buffers has
size J^3.
It should be correct if you
work it out.
So, we're charging this J^3
over B cost to J^3 elements,
which sounds like you're
charging, essentially,
one over B to each element.
Sounds great.
That means that,
so you're thinking overall,
I mean, there are N elements,
and to each one you charge a
one over B cost.
That sounds like the total
running time is N over B.
It's a bit too fast for
sorting.
We lost the log factor.
So, what's going on is that
we're actually charging to one
element more than once.
And, this is something that we
don't normally do,
never done it in this class,
but you can do it as long as
you bound that the number of
times you charge.
OK, and wherever you do a
charging argument,
you say, well,
this doesn't happen too many
times because whenever this
happens, this happens.
You should say,
you should prove that the thing
that you're charging to,
Ito charged to that think very
many times.
So here, I have a quantifiable
thing that I'm charging to:
elements.
So, I'm saying that for each
element that happened to come
into this buffer,
I'm going to charge it a one
over B cost.
How many times does one element
get charged?
Well, each time it gets charged
to, it's moved into a new
buffer.
How many buffers could it move
through?
Well, it's just going up all
the time.
Merging always goes up.
So, we start here and you go to
the next buffer,
and you go to the next buffer.
The number of buffers you visit
is the right log,
it turns out.
I don't know which log that is.
So, the number of charges of a
one over B cost to each element
is the number of buffers it
visits, and that's a log factor.
That's where we get an extra
log factor on the running time.
It is, this is the number of
levels of J funnels that you can
visit.
So, it's log K divided by log
J, if I got it right.
OK, and we're almost done.
Let's wrap up a bit.
Just a little bit more
arithmetic, unfortunately.
So, log K over log J.
Now, J^2 is like M,
roughly.
It might be square root of M.
But, log J is basically log M.
There's some constants there.
So, the number of charges here
is theta, log K over log M.
So, now this is a bit,
we haven't seen this in
amortization necessarily,
but we just need to count up
total amount of charging.
All work gets charged to
somebody, except we didn't
charge the very initial swapping
in to everybody.
But, every time we do some
swapping in, we charge it to
someone.
So, how many times does
everything it charged?
Well, there are N elements.
Each gets charged to a one over
B cost, and the number of times
it gets charged is its log K
over log M.
So therefore,
the total cost is number of
elements times a one over B
times this log thing.
OK, it's actually plus K.
We forgot about a plus K,
but that's just to get started
in the very beginning,
and start on all of the input
lists.
OK, this is an amortization
analysis to prove this bound.
Sorry, what was N here?
I assumed that I started out
with K cubed elements at the
bottom.
The total number of elements in
the bottom was K^3 theta.
OK, so I should have written
K^3 not M.
This should be almost the same
as this, OK, but not quite.
This is log based M of K,
and if you do a little bit of
arithmetic, this should be K^3
over B times log base M over B
of K over B plus K.
That's what I want to prove.
Actually there's a K^3 here
instead of a K,
but that's just a factor of
three.
And this follows because we
assume we are not in the base
case.
So, K is at least M,
which is at least B^2,
and therefore K over B is omega
square root of K.
OK, so K over B is basically
the same as K when you put it in
a log.
So here we have log base M.
I turned it into log base M
over B.
That's even worse.
It doesn't matter.
And, I have log of K.
I replaced it with K over B,
but K over B is basically
square root of K.
So in a log,
that's just a factor of a half.
So that concludes the analysis
of the funnel.
We get this crazy running time,
which is basically sorting
bound plus a little bit.
We plug that into our funnel
sort, and we get,
magically, optimal cache
oblivious sorting just in time.
Tuesday is the final.
The final is more in the style
of quiz one, so not too much
creativity, mostly mastery of
material.
It covers everything.
You don't have to worry about
the details of funnel sort,
but everything else.
So it's like quiz one but for
the entire class.
It's three hours long,
and good luck.
It's been a pleasure having
you, all the students.
I'm sure Charles agrees,
so thanks everyone.
It was a lot of fun.